the cnn journalist in gaza who has been
sharing exclusive dispatches on his
family struggle to stay alive and fight
to get out of gaza they are now out of
gaza passing safely through the rafa
crossing earlier today for 28 days
ibrahim witnessed so much tragedy pain
and fear you remember how he documented
his journey out of northern gaza with
his wife rasha who is months pregnant
and their two young sons who are 11 and
years old they started teaching
ابلغوني ان اسمي سيكون من ضمن القائمه
التي سترسل الى معبر رفح للدخول لجانب
المصري الليله الاخيره قضيتها في خانيونس
كانت هادئه جدا حتى لم نسمع اوات لا
طائرات
ولا طائرات استطلاع كانت الليله هادئه
افراد الذين كانوا معي في البيت كانوا
فرحين وحزينين في نفس
الوقت يعني كانت هناك عشره اكثر من 20 25
يوم معهم ناكل سويا نخرج سويا نشتري سويا
يعني ننام جانبا الى جانب نفرح معا نحزن
معا
ناز
شفته انتظرت انا وعائلتي ساعات عند معبر
رفح مرورا بنقاط التفتيش لكننا الان عبرنا
اخيرا احنا اليوم اجتزنا المعبر المصري
وهينا متوجهين الىى القاهره مبسوط يا خليل
ايش
بتقول اليوم لت صعبه ب نفس الوقت حلوه
وانت يا زياد الحمد لله
السلام الحمد
للهد